you taste New York is the greatest city
in the world my city I was a kid in
these streets and I made it to the top I
made my barn just doing a piece of work
for Don Carlo Gambino like that I became
a made man dad I'm thinking maybe take a
year off do you know what you're doing
to this family I will build something
that nobody can destroy so well
Castellana was a fish in the desert I
never respected Paul you killed the boss
applause you will bring down Hellfire
there is no choice you will need the
support of all five boroughs Queens
Brooklyn Manhattan Staten Island the
Browns our job now is to maintain
leadership I nominate John Gotti let
everybody off now everybody comes to
this I'm sure proud of you you should be
running your own crew now mr. Gotti are
you the head of the Gambino crime family
the head of my family mrs. Bobby do you
know your husband does nominate a tripod
John's getting too much press that can't
go unchecked
it was meant for you we've never been in
this kind of scrutiny before
what were you saying in the tapes I said
a lot of things that could get a lot of
people in trouble then say wear it up
over a cliff fear you that you would not
bring them into that well this life of
ours is a wonderful life if you can get
away with it
Johnson has been an informant for the
FBI order you fight - you can't fight no
more
never back off ever
we walk together and we fall together
this is the life
you